And we have here a most
remarkable machine,
which is being developed
by David Mitchelson.
And he, in fact, knows how to
operate this better, I think,
than anybody else does.
So he's going to help
us to get this set up.
Now, the way it
works is like this.
Inside this box of tricks
there are three mirrors,
one inside each window.
And they're rotating
at very high speed.
The two outside ones
spin about a vertical
axis about 3,000
times per minute.
And this one spins
about a horizontal axis
at the same speed.
They emit light
from the windows.
The light is reflected back
from that prism of glass
that Mr. Mitchelson is
now holding in his hand.
And the reflected light goes
back to these three mirrors.
A signal is picked
up the instant
the light hits the
mirrors, which is virtually
instantaneous in the travel.
And the angular position of
mirrors is then recorded.
From trigonometry,
the computer, then,
can work out exactly where that
little piece is, and can do it
at high speed.
And we shall be registering
the position on the xy plotter,
that I hope you can see,
as the light is moving.
No connection, except the
light, is driving the plotter
forwards and backwards as
Mr. Mitchelson moves it
in those directions.
Now, we need a volunteer
to help us with that.
And we've got somebody
kitted out, I think,
who's able to do it.
So if you'd like to come forward
and tell me what your name is--
Freya.
Freya and Dominic.
So, Freya, if you'd
like to stand there,
Dominic, just behind
me for the moment.
Take the pen in your left hand.
Move it around a little bit.
Just get the feel of the action.
And then what I'd like you to
do is to write the word "hello"
in the air.
Not too big, but nice,
gentle movements.
And you'll see that
the pen will actually
follow the writing in the
air and will spell it out
on the sheet of paper.
Fine.
Would you like to go?
That's going well.
Now, you're writing freely.
And do a nice, round
"o" at the end.
And there we are.
That's very good.
And we can see what you said.
Now
of course, that's just fun.
Doing it that way.
But it has a serious
purpose, of course,
and the purpose is clinical.
And now we have
another volunteer.
Dominic.
Dominic, who's got one of
these things stuck on his head.
Or will, in a minute, have
something stuck on his head.
We now take this off and we
imprint it on his forehead.
So that's the marker.
And the machine, now,
should detect his motions.
If you could stand just here,
on the yellow marker, there.
That's right.
That between your two feet.
And now he's facing
the mirrors and we'll
ask him to stay still.
It's impossible to
keep your head still
without swaying
slightly, and the trace
is now recording his swaying.
Would you like, now,
to stand on one leg?
More difficult to
keep still now.
Would you like to
close your eyes?
And you can see
that he's moving.
If I give him a gentle push,
then he falls right over.
Fine.
Thank you very much.